[Musique]
et avec mon ce soir pour en parler
julien ondes ou le porte parole du
rassemblement national bonsoir julien en
double merci d'être avec nous à vos
côtés fatima benomar militante féministe
mon sport fait imara benomar merci
d'être avec nous un mot tout d'abord sur
le témoignage qu'on vient d'entendre en
hiver en cachette pour porter plainte
aux policiers me dis que ce sera pas
traitée avant trois quatre semaines
est-ce que c'est tolérable odoul dans la
république française non c'est
intolérable dans la république française
et en 2021 c'est intolérable que
aujourd'hui notre civilisation
accepte que des femmes soient totalement
livrés à des prédateurs soient livrés à
des bourreaux et qu'il n'y ait pas de
réponse de l'état régalien tout d'une
part pour les protéger elle pour assurer
leur sécurité et ensuite pour
sanctionner pour punir pour incarcérer
et pour de longues peines les hommes qui
osent lever la main sur sur une femme
moi j'observe que depuis 2010 est on a
eu une succession de plans de
communication du gouvernement marlène
schiappa a été évidemment en première
ligne alors elle a eu je dirais des
paroles courageuses elle a eu en tout
cas une volonté mais derrière on a eu
surtout des mesures est derrière on a eu
du verbiage et on a eu finalement que
des plans de communication nous ce qu'on
attend c'est véritablement des actes et
il faut pas prendre je dirais les
violences faites aux femmes j'irai en
bout de chaîne si je puis dire il faut
aller en amont et surtout lutter contre
les phénomènes aujourd'hui qui sont de
vraies menaces pour les femmes notre
société il ya deux phénomènes
aujourd'hui au delà évidemment des cas
particuliers qui sont intolérables et
toutes les violences faites aux femmes
sont intolérables il ya deux phénomènes
aujourd'hui qui menace les françaises
c'est l'immigration de masse et ses
d'islamisation ces deux phénomènes là
aujourd'hui constitue une véritable un
véritable danger parce que la première
des violences faites aux femmes c'est le
refus de l'égalité entre les hommes et
les femmes et ce refus il est édictée
dans la charia la loi islamique qui
malheureusement
colonise de nombreux quartiers et
malheureusement nous avons des femmes
aujourd'hui qui son livre et à cette
idéologie au tenant de cette idéologie
et qui voient leurs droits leur liberté
reculer petit à petit alors c'est vrai
que certains médias préfèrent s'attarder
sur quelques par cas particulier
emblématique qui sont totalement
scandaleux et il faut être de tout coeur
avec les victimes moi je préfère en tout
cas je préfère l'intérêt du politique
c'est de s'intéresser au harcèlement
quotidien des femmes dans l'espace
public a le recul de leurs droits de
leurs libertés droit d'aller et venir
droit de se vêtir comme elles le
souhaitent droit tout simplement d'avoir
le mari qu'elle souhaite tout ça c'est
des enjeux de société et il faut lutter
vérité mans contre les causes de ces
dangers on va poser la question à fatima
vénaux marque connaît évidemment bien le
sujet ce que vous partagez ce même
diagnostic qui sous-entendrait que
peut-être ces victimes elles sont
davantage peut-être dans des quartiers
où se pratique la religion de l'islam si
je suis vos propos vous et merci c'est
pas ça mais en substance c'est un peu ça
il ya des violences faites aux femmes
dans tous les midis mais ce que je veux
dire c'est que les idéologies et les
populations qui aujourd'hui met à mal
les droits à la liberté des femmes oui
sont principalement issus de
l'immigration anarchique et on le voit
tous les jours dans la presse
quotidienne régionale avec des faits
divers qui sont intolérables on le voit
avec les violences sexuelles notamment
pendant les gros score et on le voit
surtout avec des quartiers qui sont
totalement sous la coupe des islamistes
qui m'avait d'avoir la réponse est sûre
sur ce diagnostic de nom et c'est
véritablement ce que avons mis tous nous
faisait obstacle nous dans notre lutte
contre les violences faites aux femmes
c'est qu'il y avait effectivement ce
refus des la société de voir le
patriarcat comme un système générateur
de violences faites aux femmes au sein
de toute la société du coup on avait
tendance à dire que les hommes violents
c'est les psy quotas pas tu sais les
migrants c'est les pauvres et donc nous
on a fait tout un travail pour produire
des enquêtes pour montrer que les
violences faites aux femmes étaient dans
tous les milieux même les plus bourgeois
par rapport aux hommes qu'ils ont l'air
au dessus de tout soupçon et avec mitsou
il ya eu tellement une libération de la
parole massive qu'on a bien vu que la
diversité des profils des hommes
violents mettaient plus à prouver et par
ailleurs
se balader j'assume mes propos dans les
couloirs de tf1 en l'air aussi
problématique que s'est baladé dans une
banlieue puisque par exemple dans la
sphère patrick poivre d'arvor il ya 24
femmes qui ont dénoncé des violences de
sa part et c'est vrai que du coup on a
l'impression qu'il ya des sommes qu'ils
ont l'air tellement éduqués sont pas eu
encore de jugement absolument mais c'est
quand même la personne dans le cadre de
mitu qui a eu le plus de plaintes enfin
deux le plus de témoignages à son
encontre par rapport au diagnostic sur
ce qui se passe par rapport aux
témoignages qui a été fait là elle parle
de quelques semaines c'est déjà pas mal
en fait la durée moyenne de
l'instruction en france par rapport aux
violences faites aux femmes c'est dix
sept mois contre deux semaines en espace
où il ya des tribunaux spécialisés
contre les violences dans le couple il
ya eu une enquête de l'inspection
générale de la justice en 2010 9 qui
montrait que dans 41 % des cas les
victimes des féminicides qui ont 100
morte était à léo vient porter plainte
ou bien déposé une main courante
80% de leur plainte avait été classée
sans suite et pourtant l'homme un moment
les a tuées donc et toute la latitude et
la posture du gouvernement a été de dire
ces femmes en fait elles ne font rien
pour se défendre donc appeler le 39 19
par les libérer votre parole allait
porter plainte or elle le faisait déjà
elle n'était pas prise au sérieux donc
nous on demandé c
en fait c'est vrai qu'il ya eu pour le
coup je suis d'accord avec vous tout un
tas de d'opérations de communication qui
saupoudre de temps en temps des voilà
enfin des initiatives vous allez pouvoir
pendant le confinement porter plainte
dans les pharmacies maintenant vous
allez pouvoir porter plainte chez la
voisine mais c est ce que nous ce qu'on
a essayé de convaincre le gouvernement
c'est qu'on voulait un programme global
un branle bas de combat comme il ya eu
en espagne avec la loi-cadre c'est à
dire avec tout un programme qui va de la
sensibilisation à l'école de l'éducation
contre le sexisme des plus de moyens
plus de
deux dispositifs de défense des femmes
un suivi des hommes violents c'est pas
parce qu'on passe dix ans en prison
qu'on en sort débarrasser de ses démons
au contraire la prison est plutôt en
environnement ces pathogènes donc des
expériences qui se sont déjà avérés
vertueuse comme chez explique monsieur
frémiot qui a été magistrat qui a mis en
place des foyers d'accompagnement des
hommes violents pour qu'il travaille a
dit construire leur violence et tout ça
doit être un programme cohérent tant
qu'on aura des petites initiatives
plutôt tourné vers la communication qui
sont saupoudrés par ci par là on
n'arrivera pas un bilan satisfaisant je
vous rappelle que cette année on est à
80 11 victimes de féminicide sur 285
jours ça on fait une tous les trois ans
et dès que je suis militante féministe
depuis 2009 maintenant je commence à
être une vieille féministe on est
toujours à une moyenne d'une femme qui
meurt tous les deux jours et demi ou
tous les trois jours julien en douleur
main 91 femmes un tueur en 2021 que
propose marine le pen pour endiguer ce
phénomène
marine le pen propose de mettre à l'abri
les femmes qui sont victimes de
violences conjugales c'est à dire de les
sortir d'une partie de leurs de leur
prison parce que le
quand les femmes sont victimes de lens
conjugales le domicile devient une
prison et ensuite évidemment de sévir
contre les hommes violents c'est à dire
que nous avons assisté à ces dernières
années de multiples faits divers où vous
avez des récidivistes où vous aviez des
plaintes qu'ils n'étaient pas entendues
aux alliés des alertes vous avez des
signalements et petit à petit qu'ils
n'étaient pas écoutés et ça peut se voir
comment ça se termine électronique est
un échec non mais le bracelet
électronique excusez moi moi je prends
toujours l'exemple dramatique alors
effroyable le père hamel en 2016 a été
égorgé par un individu par un islamiste
qui portait un bracelet électronique
voilà donc le bracelet électronique ne
satisfait que l'institution judiciaire
parce que c'est un palliatif à la prison
on sait qu'il ya un manque de places de
prison on sait qui manque au moins
quarante mille places de prisons marine
le pen les construira on a vu que ce
gouvernement nonobstant les promesses
des monnaies le maquereau en 2007 a été
incapable de construire au moins 3000
places de prison ce qui est largement
insuffisant les a conduits à quoi ça
conduit évidemment à laisser les
prédateurs dans la nature qui vont
pouvoir récidiver et ensuite j'en
reviens quand même parce que c'est
important j'en reviens à gérer les
phénomènes qui génère les violences au
quotidien qui sont l'immigration de
masse et qui sont l'islamisation si on
ne s'attaque pas à ces deux phénomènes
se dire arrêter l'immigration arrêtez de
faire venir des individus qui ne
partagent pas notre culture qui rejette
égalité entre les hommes et les femmes
les afghans que nous faisons venir sont
à 92% ça a été prouvé partisans de la
charia donc de l'inégalité entre les
hommes et les femmes est donc de
traitements dégradants ils sont pour
l'effacement de la femme dans l'espace
public ils sont pour sa relégation au
niveau du foyer tout ça est intolérable
et ses violences là malheureusement
elles ont pignon sur rue elles sont
banalisés quand vous voyez qu au
parlement européen vous avez des
mouvements de jeunes proche des frères
musulmans qui exhibe et qui se victimise
avec le voile islamiste qui est une
violence contre les droits des femmes
contre les libertés des femmes et contre
notre je dirais notre notre idée de la
femme nous en europe et en france tout
ça aujourd'hui et soutenu il faut
évidemment lutte et éradiquer dynamisme
pour protéger les droits et libertés des
femmes fatima benomar il y un travail
vraiment de changement des mentalités en
france à une d actu du jour ans
l'international lucas hernandez en
équipe de france de munich notamment qui
est qui risque l'incarcération
clairement il est convoqué devant la
justice espagnole est-ce que ça par
exemple c'est quelque chose qu'on voit
en france une personnalité qui est
susceptible de faire de la prison pour
violences conjugales parce qu'il n'a pas
respecté une convocation notamment de
justice c'est la mentalité française
qu'il faut changer oui parce que là
aussi je m'inscris en faux pas pour a
jusqu'au 10 julien au dulce
malheureusement faux de dire qu'il est
inscrit dans l'adn de la culture
française hégémonique une lutte contre
le sexisme pour l'égalité femmes hommes
etc il ya un très bon livre qui
s'appelle une culture de jijel à la
française que je vous invite à lire et
par exemple quelqu'un comme eric zemmour
pour parler des présidentielles qu'on
peut pas soupçonner d'être un islamiste
disait je le cite dans les termes le
match le sexisme et le machisme n'existe
pas ce sont des termes idéologiques
ostracisant un comportement masculin
authentique naturel je le cite dans le
texte je connais très bien cette tirade
donc c'est pour vous dire que
malheureusement n'y a pas les islamistes
qui ont une image d'inégalité entre les
femmes et les hommes ce qui est vrai par
ailleurs mais a contrario en france une
idéologie hégémonie qui dit qu'on est
pour l'égalité femmes hommes et contre
le sexisme et par ac par l'amour
courtois nous sommes pays le pays qui a
je dirais fait l'éloge de la femme qui
avait battu c'est parce que caricaturale
quand même parce que c'est vrai que
voilà on met geste est pour filles et
pour finir je pense qu'il a bien assez
malheureusement la réalité mais c'est
malheureusement la lan en réalité mais
en tout cas je pense que depuis mitsou
on pourrait au moins se débarrasser de
ses a priori qu'en france et justement
il ya six profils jeunes qui sont au
dessus de tout soupçon ces hommes et qui
sont pointés du doigt on aurait pu dire
que justement il avait un rapport très
égalitaire très respectueux des femmes
et pourtant non c'est faux et donc un
moment il faut sortir de ce mythe là ça
ce sont les mythes constitutive de la
france tous les hommes sont des
prétendants je n'ai pas dit ça j'ai dit
qu'il ya d'autres discours de la
déconstruction vise et cible numéro six
mois tous comme de potentiels fraudeurs
mais le poteau cegeka seule une version
cela-dit c'est de la diversion je ne
suis pas pour aller vers les individus
je parle d'un système qui est générateur
de sexisme et de machisme en france je
viens d'envoyer pas de payer juste ça
rapport à ce que je voulais dire on est
maintenant cinq ans après mis tout on
est deux ans après le grenelle contre
les violences faites aux femmes et on
n'a pas de résultats et malheureusement
on n'a pas eu le quinquennat qu'on
souhaitait pour l'égalité femmes hommes
pourtant c'était la grande cause du
quinquennat on devrait maintenant pour
voir on parlait justement pendant la
campagne présidentielle et sortir de ces
poncifs mime et de tout ça c'est le gros
backlash qu'on a subi les féministes et
me dire de toute façon vous dites que
tous les hommes sont des quand est-ce
qu'on a théorisé ça est ce que j'ai
écrit des livres sur ça ne vous pouvez
trouver aucune ligne de ma part en train
de théoriser ça jamais eu assez de
production théorique féministes pour
pouvoir sortir de ces caricatures de
toute façon vous êtes anti homme c'est
pas vrai même des livres kiki caroline
de haas n'est pas anti homme dans ses
discours et dans ses écrits qu'est ce
qu'elle a écrit son d'anti
excusez moi mais dans tout temps toutes
ces manifestations n'ont touché ni
j'aurais aimé attendait à ce qu est une
hostilité profonde contre les hommes qui
fait passer la couleur
français berline entre les barres j'ai
trouvé là une ligne où elle dit une
chose pareille surtout les hommes sont
des agresseurs en faisant condé cesse ce
témoin nous dire dans le reportage a été
accueilli par des policières qui m'ont
dit mais qu'est ce que tu lui as fait
pour qu'il te mettre dans cet état là ça
vous inspire quoi ça se sont pas des
hommes qui problème charia c'est une
femme policière qui manifestement été
extrêmement mal formés est ce qu'il ya
un vrai aussi problème de formation de
la part des policiers
sur ce problème de violence conjugale ce
n'est pas acceptable
et c'est une douleur supplémentaire pour
la plaignante qui attend de l'ecoute qui
attend du soutien et il faut l'entourer
évidemment je pense de formation
des chats des chiens
je vous texte et qui parle pas tellement
des femmes finalement dans un ciel en
salle beaucoup l on parle beaucoup elle
en parle beaucoup parce que justement
déjà c'est une femme et ça fait beaucoup
de différence
si bien sûr que si
l'on parle beaucoup et vous savez il ya
effectivement des
échappées
effectivement parce que je veux bien
mais on se trompe de débat je suis
désolé de le dire mais on se trompe de
débat aujourd'hui nous sommes dans une
société française où les droits et
libertés des femmes reculent c'est un
fait c'est un fait et où les femmes sont
harcelées dans leur quotidien dans les
transports dans l'espace public en
allant au travail et sont harcelés
toujours par les mêmes alors je sais que
ça ne plaît pas à la bien pensant
toujours par les mêmes toujours parler
qui les cible ce qui les agressent qui
les insultent dans la rue il suffit de
sortir dans la rue et 2
de voir les témoignages des femmes
notamment dans l'espace public dans les
transports dans le métro dans les ter
dans toutes les régions sont toujours
les mêmes qui les harcèlent donc pour
les protéger je le dis et je le redis
pour les protéger il faut arrêter le
phénomène migratoire qui aujourd'hui si
je met à mal et
on a marre il ya une scène où une femme
politique cécile duflot se fait siffler
puisque vous parlez si finement à
l'assemblée nationale c'était pas un
migrant qui l'a sifflé il ya eu juste un
collectif de d'assistant des
parlementaires
juste les six mois terminés film
raconterait commune un collectif
d'assistante parlementaire au sénat qui
a qui s'est constitué pour montrer qu'il
y avait du harcèlement sexuel à l'inde
dans les couloirs du sénat vous n'allez
pas me dire que la moyenne des sénateurs
sont des jeunes hommes des banlieues il
ya eu 100 % des femmes qui ont été
harcelés dans les transports en commun
oui c'est parti et vous allez m'aider
16% des miss n'est pas avare 60 ans est
en effet un voyage initiatique du
ministère de l'intérieur et là vous me
parlez excusez moi mais ça n'a rien à
voir vous me parlez de sifflet contre
ces signes du toulouse moi je dis moi je
dis moi je vais pas je vous parlais
juste je vais vous parler à fait décider
moi je voudrais pas encore une fois je
vais je sais je vous
réponds vous avez parlé de sifflet
l'assemblée nationale moi je vous
parlais du calvaire et du dumas salazie
le shine aise chahinez qui a été torturé
qui étaient brûlés vifs parce qu'elle
voulait s'habiller la française voilà la
raison nombreux quartiers français mini
ou les droits et libertés le clip passer
les femmes qui sont torturés et tués
parce qu'elles veulent vivre à la
française et kevin lowe 10 la mise en
effet aujourd'hui les enfants fr a suivi
n'ai pas réponse féminicide iliad et
shahinez et à des femmes qui ont été
tués par des non français donc ça suffit
cette diversion c'est complètement
contre-productif et les objets contre
l'espagne est juste fois plus de moyens
pour lutter contre ces phénomènes d'une
manière globale et qu'elle a de meilleur
résultat qu'en france c'est ce qu'ont
rassemblement national vous êtes prêt à
mettre davantage de moyens sur ce thème
la pression je ne parle pas de
l'immigration général sur ce thème la bd
violences faites aux femmes des
violences conjugales évidemment qu'il
faut des moyens mais il faut surtout des
moyens pour la justice
sans des moyens pour la justice en fait
on ne pourra pas sévir on ne pourra pas
protéger parce que on a oublié que la
prison au delà d'être un instrument de
réinsertion c'est d'abord un instrument
de protection protection pour les
victimes et quand j'écoutais 7,7 victime
qui disait au 8 août il aura plus son
prince électronique ça va recommencer et
qu'ils appréhendaient avec angoisse il
faut qu'ils aient des peines exemplaires
exemplaires et de la prison ferme pas
des remises de peine pas du sursis parce
qu'on sait très bien que sur six c'est
le droit de recommencer pour que les
femmes soient protégés donc qui aura 40
qu'il passe de prison qui seront
construits par marine le pen donc on
aura une justice qui ne sera plus
laxistes kiné qui aura le courage de
sévir contre les bourreaux et les
prédateurs et oui on aura cette volonté
excusez-moi de je le redis de couper
l'immigration pour assurer la sécurité
dans l'espace public est d'éradiquer
d'islamisme qui encore une fois met à
mal les libertés des femmes en france
merci en tout cas à tous les deux fatima
benomar julien houle d'avoir accepté ce
face à face et c'est la fin de set